most important person in the world can't
fly off to the most dangerous place in
the world who else can no one they knew
the risk when they left you can't win
the throne if you're dead can't break
the wheel if you're dead it's dangerous
for everybody involved I'm sure it's
good for both of them in the moment but
you don't even get the relief of how
beautiful it could be or should be its
no just it's not good but it should be
but it's not just as everything was
coming together everyone's gonna join
together to fight inevitably Game of
Thrones will tear us apart
hey everybody so there's all kinds of
teary and stuff happening in season
eight Peter Dinklage's made a lot of
comments before the season after the
season in the clip that I just included
this suggests a little bit about what
the basis for the conflict within Team
Daenerys is going to be all about
because you have Jon Snow Daenerys
coming together you have Tyrion who's
really worried about it and then bran
also making comments about how this is
going to tear us all apart and that's
just part of Game of Thrones that's just
part of the fun of the story just as you
come together something inevitably tears
you apart so I've sort of already done
in general predictions for all the
storylines but I wanted to do a Tyrion
video because there's some really cool
stuff that was circulating right around
the finale that goes all the way back to
George RR Martin's original outline
which suggests a couple possible
outcomes for Tyrion Daenerys Jon Snow so
I'll try to explain all this and then
how I think it'll actually end up going
down because some of this I believe some
of this I do not believe but it's
actually a valid theory which is like
the other most fun part of Game of
Thrones is coming up with fan theories
so just careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened on the season
so far so a lot of people saw this
moment in the finale and they wondered
what was going on and Tyrion said there
was a quote from Peter Dinklage and the
clip that I included where he is just
absolutely terrified of what's going to
happen now that Jon Snow and Daenerys
are actually getting together like they
came together as allies now they're
getting together for both sexes and he's
starting to get really worried which is
why I included that other clip too if
you die if something bad happens to you
then we're all lost so we haven't quite
got to the point where we have all the
Starks and all of team Daenerys in the
same place at once but as you can see
from the clips Tyrion
only cares about Daenerys he thinks that
she is the Promised One
he might not totally believe in the
prophecy but he believes that she is the
one that's going to bring this all
together so while he doesn't think that
Jon Snow is a liar like we saw earlier
in the season we spent time together
I do trust what he says here is you
stupid things and they die he's more
worried about what Jon Snow is gonna do
in all this so you can sort of see where
the dividing line is you have Tyrion
Varys Daenerys and then on the other
side of this you have all the stark
children in Jon Snow like Isaac
Hempstead
right has already said that the other
star children won't think of Jon Snow
differently when they find out about his
secret Targaryen heritage he'll still be
Jon Snow their brother they're not gonna
call him some different name but it just
sort of establishes where everyone's
allegiances are so Tyrion really cares
about Daenerys I know a lot of people
think there's more behind that and I'll
explain why because it's George RR
Martin's original outline for Game of
Thrones and that's sort of the basis for
this theory is that if you've forgotten
about it a couple years ago George R
Martin's original treatment for Game of
Thrones he has a sort of three book
outline where he had character arcs
mapped out was leaked onto the Internet
and part of that plot was this big arias
storyline where Tyrion and Jon Snow
would battle for her affections so if
you hadn't picked up on it already
George or Martin is all about the incest
struggle we have the Lannisters we have
the Targaryen family in the history of
Westeros now we have Jon Snow and
Daenerys but it's just that instead of
on the TV show as we see now Jon Snow
and Daenerys getting that storyline it
was going to be Arya and Jon Snow and
presumably that version of Arya was
going to be much older or so just forget
about Maisie Williams
the story ended up being much different
he expanded it into the seven books that
we see now and the story sort of shifted
to Jon Snow and Daenerys but in the way
the Dan and Dave sort of circled back
around and grabbed old plot lines and
old ideas a lot of people think that
that's where this Tyrion look comes from
is that it's scooter sort of serve as
the basis for season eight conflict
because even though you may not have
believed that Jon Snow and Sansa would
have spent all that time arguing in
Winterfell at the beginning of the
season they still did that even though I
totally didn't buy that it was gonna
happen and obviously the outcome was is
that they recognized that they were
brother and sister they needed to work
together Jon Snow truly believed in her
in handed the north to her as warden s
while he was away the other less gross
side of this is tyrion has been Daenerys
his closest advisor she looks to him but
around the middle of the season
towards the end she started to look to
Jon Snow like anytime there was a
decision to be made Jon Snow would speak
up she would just look to him and say
okay that's what we're gonna do Jon was
the one that sold her on the plan to go
north of the wall even though it was
originally Tyrians plan you know however
bad that you thought that plan
John was also the one that suggested
boat to go to white Harbor so that we
could get to boat sex whether or not
that was actually on his mind there was
this sort of implied romance that was
going on between them while they were at
Dragonstone you have to imagine that
because of the way the show jumps in
time that they were together on
Dragonstone
for weeks and weeks and weeks it just
they didn't spell that out it's just you
know when you see you're on flying all
over the place like he's teleporting you
just have to remember that there are
great stretches of time even between
individual scenes within episodes so
even though it doesn't seem like they've
been together for a while they've
actually been together for almost a year
by the end of the season so like back
during Episode four when Daenerys gets
really curious and excited about the
idea of what happened with grey worm and
they gave each other that knowing look
when Jon Snow walks up it just implies
that that was going on in the background
the whole time and the show just chose
not to show a lot of it you cut to the
end of the season Daenerys is ready to
throw her life away and take her
greatest asset her dragons up north of
the wall to rescue Jon Snow from this
crazy plan and tyrion is trying to do
everything he can to stop her if you're
lost everything is lost and she's just
like hard pass I've already put on my
winter gear even Sir Jorah has sort of
made his peace with it like at the end
of the season when they're like we'll
take the boat in sir Jorah sort of looks
at the look that Jon Snow shares with
Daenerys and it's like oh I get what's
going on here okay whatever but based on
this look the Tyrion gives them at the
end it seems like he is the one person
inside team Daenerys who just is not
cool with any of this
however Varys feels about it he might
shrug a little bit but it seems like
he's mostly team Tyrion so if Tyrion was
really worried about something and
wanted to stop this Jon Snow Daenerys
thing that Varys would probably back his
play so it seems like the show really is
building towards the reveal of Jon Snow
being a Targaryen them doing the George
R Martin incest struggle thing like how
do we deal with our relationship what
does this mean now that we're related
that doesn't even get into the idea that
Jon Snow is now ahead of Daenerys in the
line of succession that's like it's sort
of an extra layer on top of things that
we can talk about in another video but
in this moment here Tyrion doesn't know
anything about that so he's already
probably going to try and tear them
apart
just to keep this from blowing up in
their faces like let's keep this
aboveboard until the war for the dawn is
over then once Daenerys is on the throne
she can take as many suitors as she
wants but if there's any real tension
between Tyrion and John it'll probably
be more over who Daenerys is listening
to it you know not so much the affection
of Daenerys but the attention of
Daenerys because even though Jon Snow
has a lot of good ideas he's also had a
lot of bad ideas just like Tyrion but I
think arguably most of Tyrians bad ideas
can be blamed on sort of the contrivance
of season 7 in the idea that they want
to balance the scales 14 lannister and
team Daenerys so we've already talked a
little bit about how they're setting
Jamie up for Season eight like they want
him to seem like a good battle commander
so that he can fill that role for
Daenerys because Tyrion is terrible at
battle planning on the TV show even
though I don't think that that's true to
the character so you have to imagine
that Jon Snow is gonna be riding on
Ragle with Daenerys while she's on
drogon so you'd actually need somebody
on the ground to lead the army and
that's really where Jamie comes in
but speaking of Tyrion not being so hot
with the idea of incest and Jon Snow and
Daenerys can you imagine what Jamie is
gonna say about all this when he gets up
there and he also learns the truth of
the matter now he might be sympathetic
to Jon but he also would probably say
that it's not a good idea to so that's
just something else to think about
everybody not being really cool with the
idea of Jon Snow and Daenerys getting
together but there's this great sense of
inevitability so as we do more bonus
videos in the off season and we learn a
little bit about what's going on with
the characters we can start talking
about the way it'll actually play down
but ultimately I'm an optimist so just
like they did with the Winterfell plot
with Arya and Sansa with Jon and Sansa
they'll resolve their differences
everything will come together by the end
it's just a question of how that's going
to happen so let me know in the comments
what do you think that tyrion is going
to do in season 8 to try and get between
Jon Snow in Daenerys and do you think
it'll only be political or do you
actually think that he cares about
Daenerys in a much deeper way so because
we're sliding into season 8 stuff what's
gonna happen is as my Q&A tomorrow will
be a season 8 focused Q&A but if there's
any question that you want me to include
in that just
write it below in the comments I will
keep doing weekly q and A's in addition
to bonus videos as long as people are
interested in it so just submit all the
stuff that you guys want me to put in
that but there is a new round of that
Game of Thrones giveaway it's for HBO
now subscriptions all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video congratulations to the
last winner EDF please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details you can
click here for my broader season 8
predictions and you can click here to
learn all about Aegon Targaryen thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight